what's going on guys
last night the biggest night in
Hollywood the 89th Academy Awards that
means it's time for the screen junkies
recap show the fifth annual grouchy's it
was a night full of glamour with old
friends reuniting Ryan Gosling
terrifying unsuspecting tourists Chrissy
Teigen takin a nap
cookie wanting cookies and the most
controversial ending since The Sopranos
join me as we recap the highs and lows
of this year's Academy Awards and if you
think we're just going to gloss over
that insane ending you're not today's
episode is brought to you by the
uncarrier introducing t-mobile 1-all
unlimited all-in first up one of our
favorites the BuzzFeed tip of the night
the nominees are Nicole Kidman's weird
flipper clap Mel Gibson's variety of
awkward and/or crazy faces and the
winner is Denzel Washington's fu face to
Casey Affleck one of the first people
who contact was Senza washington and i
just meant it's nice the first time
thank you
there's nothing like being told by a guy
with a disheveled man but holding your
Oscars that he met you today and he's a
really big fan Denzel wasn't having it
ladies and gentlemen this is the why are
you doing this award the nominees are
random clips of Javier Bardem watching
The Bridges of Madison County
lin-manuel miranda is doing his hamilton
rap sing before songs that he had no
role in as a performer he only wrote
some music and the winner is Viola Davis
first you brought up corpses and grave
robbing and your acceptance you know
there's one place that all the people
with the greatest potential are gathered
and that's the graveyard and then you
apply only actors are capable of
understanding people we are the only
profession that celebrates what it means
to live a life without journalists or
therapists teachers parents or square
writers who wrote the words that your
character said Viola Davis love your
performance and senses but the award so
many shows the gravity of the season why
are you doing this this next one has
been years in the making it's the John
Travolta inappropriate touching award
named for serial inappropriate touch her
John Travolta the nominees are Jimmy
Kimmel lifting adorable child Sonny
Pilar Milana star Oh leak ravallo
getting hit with a flag and the winner
is the tour bus guy kissing everyone's
hand this guy got very up close and
personal with some of Hollywood's
biggest stars and then he goes into
hands an Oscar winner a camera to take a
selfie for him not with him for him dude
respect I wouldn't have the balls to do
that nice is up whoo this next one's a
doozy it's the different cultures or
weird award the winner is Jimmy Kimmel
for feeling it necessary to make fun of
the following names when your name is
Mahalo what do you name the kid you
can't go with like a me real simple
my name is URI what your name's Euler II
rise with jewelry well I know it rhymes
with jewelry wow that's some name what's
your name my name is Patrick see that's
a name all right all right names huh
people sure do have different ones
sometimes this is the surprise of the
night award the nominees are Oh Jay
Simpson indirectly winning an Oscar
Academy Award winner Suicide Squad that
seems weird to say landing the DCE you
and Oscar before the MCU that's right
look it up I know we did just how tiny
this guy al Garcia Bernal is in real
life due to standing next to someone who
as of last year was at the age of 17
still super tiny and the winner is of
course it's the colossal train wreck
that ended this show it was such a
massive disaster who we've created our
own special subset of grouchy's called
the
for the best of the end of the 2017
oestrus an academy I hope for your sake
that this is not an annual event because
likes first up the here follows this
sword award it goes to Warren Beatty who
saw that something was really off about
the card that he pulled out of the
envelope pretended to be too old to read
it then in an act worthy of the red
wedding hands his friend Faye Dunaway
the card lalala throwing her under the
bus harder than speeds Jack Traven Bravo
Clyde this is the conspiracy theory
award because what's a disaster without
a conspiracy theory sure Emma Stone
claims she had the Best Actress envelope
with her the whole time but who is she
really covering up for journey down the
rabbit hole with me who was the last
person we saw with the Best Actress
envelope this before it made its way
into warren beatty's hand cuz that's
right
leonardo dicaprio yes leo
the man snubbed by the academy so long
and so hard that he had to eat raw bison
liver and jump in a frozen lake just to
get over the hump and riddle me this
what is real been doing the past year
since he won nothing no I'll tell you
what he was up to meticulously planning
his revenge biding his time until the
moment was right for him to like like a
cobra swapping out the Best Actress for
the Best Picture envelope in a final fu
to the show that effed him up so many
times for me next up on the n DS the
glass act award the nominees are Jimmy
Kimmel for definitely taking the blame
for the situation and finding some humor
in the movie
personally I blame Steve Harvey for this
the la-la-land producer who helped
everyone cut to the chase and flat out
said we lost we lost by the way the
winner is Jordan Horowitz the la-la-land
producer who and what had to be one of
the most crushing public disappointments
of his or anyone's life had the Grayson
boys to say he'd be happy to give the
Oscar in his hands to moonlight I'm
going to be really proud to hand this to
my friends for moonlight yes that were
me I would just unleash a
profanity-laced tirade and just run to
the exit moonlight you guys won Best
Picture this is not a joke Jordan
Horowitz you sir are a class act
this one is the sillier saying there's a
chance award this one goes to the eight
other nominees for Best Picture who upon
finding out there been a mistake no
there's a mistake had they're dashed
hopes briefly reignited everyone's
talking about moonlight shocking win but
let's not forget about those poor
producers of movies like this lion or
hell or high-water that for one brief
shining moment thought wait maybe I
really did win there's a mistake only to
find out enough hopefully you spilled it
in the first year were two movies were
announced as Best Picture
neither of them with you you double log
this is the best cinematography award
with all due respect to the actual
winner line of Sangren the cameraman who
captured the close-up of lala land
producer Jordan Horowitz holding up the
envelope with the real winner was the
best cameraman in the building last
night Congrats nameless crew member your
work will live on and useless montages
of moments from past ceremonies for
decades of austere shows to come and I
bet it's getting a lot of retweets oh
boy it's the you had one job award this
award goes to Bryan Cullinan and Martha
Ruiz the accountants in charge of the
envelopes for the Oscars in a story
published just a couple of days ago they
themselves describe their jobs as
handing the envelopes to someone and
making sure they're getting the right
envelopes and the contents in them are
accurate come on you had one job if
Warren Beatty doesn't have the wrong
envelope moonlight wins cleanly and we'd
all be talking about this Halle Berry's
weird
there and how orange Alicia vikander was
and now the final award of the evening
that n DS reaction of the night award if
you want to see how 10 movie lovers
genuinely reacted to one of the biggest
screw-ups in Oscar history look no
further than this clip from our live
watch party last night what started as a
routine wrap up to our Oscar watch party
soon turned into absolute chaos if you
want to have a good time go back and
watch each person's individual reaction
you're gonna see joy anger shock
heartbreak
surprise all the things we love about
the Oscars wrapped into a neat package
of what the hell did we just witness
that's it for the N DS and the grouchy
so what were your favorite moments of
the Academy Award who got snubbed tell
us in the comments section below
we want to know I want to thank you for
watching screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick
hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
we'd like to thank our sponsor t-mobile
t-mobile one is all unlimited all-in
switch today hey guys did you know that
this n card works with your phone now
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show and more